here in las vegas some students staged a
walkout this afternoon in support of
women's rights jeremy j ford is at clark
high school with reaction from the rally
students at clark high are protesting
women's rights and some of the girls
that i spoke to say it's their body and
their choice
[Music]
these high school protesters are being
vocal on how they feel about the
possibility of the supreme court
overturning roe versus wade with
national protests happening across the
country high school senior blue mahari
told me she didn't want to miss the
opportunity to be heard i think it's
just too important not to miss
i mean it's been law for almost 50 years
now it's protected
the right to abortion for people all
over this country it's just absolutely
essential to me that i came out here
today throughout the afternoon students
rallied outside the school for more than
30 minutes holding protest signs
chanting and writing pro-abortion
messages on the sidewalks in las vegas
jeremy j ford live local now